hello and welcome to this video mosque
or whatever yeah I cannot do it and I'm
doing something else now usually I get
them this what is called the snake Ben
Oni against him and I just want
something different this time I got a
ready system and fairly that's a fairly
nice opening line from white when white
has a slight advantage let's see how to
do it queen bee three as an interesting
idea like a queen b 6i can start with
Bishop e3 and then queen bee three
that's also interesting and then we do
that so difficult to say that quite a
number of interesting options okay so
what does this idea he wants to play
Bishop a six-lane or seems to be but
anyway I'll do that might be 6 SC 5 so
yeah I thought that Queen a form I just
wonder take first then Queen a4 yeah
let's take for us and then play Queen a
form that's probably a bit simpler don't
really know what what is this move now
yes but now I have 95 and 95 as good
moves so night what what is better 95
know it seems better
496 let's do that let's grab the and
push up air and turn also the light
squares are nice to have yeah this is in
fact the move which I did not really
appreciate that much night comes to see
for now and probably means that this
isn't so bad for black and the normal
circumstance it would be pretty terrible
that he had to give up that light square
Bishop here but that looks fairly active
okie dokie so my development is not
great is he going from 95 maybe let's
put this only one Bishop f6 is also
something that he might have planned
okay um yeah and I have to go back and
now I'm threatening 95 I think so I
think he has to react to that somehow
now I can take on d5 with the bishop it
looks pretty bad
now the whole configuration was kind of
shaky the awkward problem is that this
is also double attack on the rook and
the noid so it seems he has to take yeah
so this is just two points Queen hang c4
hang c7 eggs that's a bit much okay um
question is Quincy for or not probably
not a check let's do it like that i can
try to move the King now way okay it
wouldn't have changed much so what is he
turning to do probably moving the night
somewhere the ship here looks good yeah
so what now Queen a for I guess for
group d 7 and attacking a seven also
covers c2 sorry about my voice I got a
slight cold and not much that I can do
expecting no upside I expected f5 this
looked like pretty awkward pin to me
yeah let's just double four loop d8 yeah
root yet I guess
black resins young was yeah I'm not sure
at first I thought that that would be
really nice but I think it's not that
that bad for him quinby eight is an
interesting move according to the comp
and a six hmm I really don't believe
that like a slightly better as a
computer says this this yeah but this
isn't I mean this shouldn't be too bad
definitely for black but maybe yeah
maybe he has to go to be six years old
I'm sorry yeah I had to kill that sound
ya hear it okay queen bee six losses but
he has to do something else the engine
suggests going back to the night which
is already then not ideal he can
definitely improve before then yeah now
it's really hit just over due to this
due to this tactic can go to two points
and the position the bishop on you three
will also be much much stronger than the
night as it has no outpost and black
really has no activity yeah it was a
surprisingly quick turn of events but
what I'm kind of fascinated with us that
this is supposed to be better for black
according to the comp oh sorry it's so
activity really yeah maybe it's a case
and the bishop on g2 is not yet doing
that much possible yeah possible I mean
bleh it's not giving the computer is not
giving black a key advantage just like
0.3 or something but we are see the seam
okay well thanks for watching